i love these segments because i actually
love to try and learn something uh you
uh
were in on and and helped with assisted
with one of the biggest discoveries in
science in recent memory the higgs
particle is that correct yes okay
uh that's all the time we have uh
convert that's really all i needed to
know uh the higgs particle i have read
about the higgs particle and i'll be
honest i don't understand what it is can
you give us a sort of layman's
explanation of what the higgs particle
is it's the most beautiful ridiculous
story the prediction which dates back to
the 1960s is that sometime after the
universe got to the size of a melon
and remember the universe today has got
350 billion galaxies in it each 100
billion stars once upon a time it was
the size of a melon some point after
that it was expanding and cooling and
something crystallized or condensed out
into empty space like almost like maple
syrup or something the universe gets
filled with this stuff as it cools and
today now we are massive we are solid
because our particles are interacting
with that cosmic treacle or whatever you
want to call it so what you're saying is
that if it weren't for this and i love
that i asked you to explain it dumb it
down for me
and you said it's molasses uh
essentially essentially molasses but
you're saying that all the particles in
the universe need to be held together by
something and this is the glue if you
will that's holding everything together
in a way it's it you get mass so these
particles are solid because they're
interacting with this stuff except for
light which isn't which travels at speed
of light because it doesn't interact
with it i'm i'm fascinated by people
that think on this level i mean i walk
around i've been on this earth quite a
long time and i don't think about it i
think there's a cup
but you're actually thinking about the i
mean for someone to conceptualize this
and then set out to prove that it exists
and then prove that it exists this is
the beautiful thing this is a prediction
from the 1960s a mathematical prediction
then about 10 years ago we decided to
build the biggest scientific experiment
ever built 16 miles in circumference
underneath geneva we accelerate protons
which are these simple particles to
99.9999999 percent the speed of light at
which they circumnavigate this ring
eleven thousand times you get them
spinning around this ring really fast on
the other way we collide together 600
million of these every second in every
collision we create the conditions that
were present less than a billionth of a
second after the big bang we take
photographs of those 600 million
collisions per second and we find out
this guy from 1965
was right which is i think one of the
most remarkable achievements well it's
true of einstein too einstein made
predictions he had theories that
couldn't be proven for many years and
then later on someone would come along
and prove it
the best einstein prediction we we
discovered a thing called a double
pulsar which is two stars the mass of
the sun compressed into something about
the size of la so imagine the mass of
the sun into something size of la
they're rotating around each other about
once every two days one of them spinning
40 times a second the other one's going
around once every two seconds and
einstein predicts that they fall into
each other at a rate of seven
millimeters a day in 1916 that that
theory 1916 makes its prediction right
and a few years ago we we find this
thing we do the measurement and we find
out it's true these things these two
styles drifted in at seven millimeters a
day in perfect accord with so all these
yeah 60 years after his death you find
out he was absolutely right about
something right it couldn't be proven in
his lifetime